it's twitch hey everybody welcome to
Monday melee yeah thank you for joining
us we're very excited and we're also a
little sad first of all we're excited
because we're playing farming simulator
15 today look at this whoa amazing crazy
we're a little sad because it's Steve
Smith's last twitch YouTube stream last
Monday melee he's leaving this is last
week at Conan and Team Coco but he's
here today and so to celebrate we
thought we'd play the greatest game ever
made farming simulator it's definitely
my favorite I've never
we haven't fired this up yet I have no
idea what to expect
Steve do you want to read us the back of
enough to hold back don't worry about it
all right it's uh I'm excited because it
says over 140 authentic machines and
farming tools including exclusive
vehicles from over 40 famous
manufacturers and also this farming
simulator 15 features a brand new thing
wood cutting that's right so let's get
into a wood cutting this is gonna be
awesome wood let's chop some wood your
wood that's great
now I don't I don't know how I would do
as a farmer I feel like I have kind of a
black thumb not a green thumb yeah are
you good at growing things or not I have
a lot of plants in my apartment yeah
there we go like plants a lot there we
go oh yeah
already I love this coming this fall the
EBC family farming simulator 15 dr. hex
play says hi Steve
[Music]
this is a great outfit I'm really
excited about this
[Music]
I don't know I don't know I don't know
great opening pharmacy they're all right
let's do a career multiplayer Slayers
let's do career ooh is it local no I
think you have to sign in now where
should we go
you're born a spoon or another you
already know they're giving us so many
options yeah the Scandinavian area
represents an important agricultural
center in the middle of North North
forest show Bjorn homes residents how a
modern farm is run this map also
contains a tour oh that introduces the
game fundamentals try your luck in the
new world the new world America's
brought my hundreds of years the new
world this game is obviously should we
go Bjorn home or a Westbridge I said do
you think we're gonna do the tour or do
we just want to get into it let's just
get into it alright Scandinavia today
also we've got a new guy on the old ones
and twos it's Chris Weller Chris
completed say hi that's right and that's
all you'll ever see of him that's all
you'll ever see
Beth Marat skis in the chat room Jason
O'Malley creeper in the corner game is
being loaded so far I got to say really
impressed with this game yeah I like the
menu system the UI design is very nice
new opening was fantastic all the
different skies that I'm looking at or
are pretty yeah a lot of pretty skies
Beth what do you think about farming
simulator 15 how does it rate against
the 14 and 13 they plan for it your
press looks top left we're moving around
guys have left do we want a shirt guided
tour yeah yeah let's do it only this
whoa all right first-person huh first
people know that's an interesting choice
for Ravi Seeley
guns I don't know it just turns to do it
oh well okay if you click the Lexx
left stick you see the weather forecast
wait a second so we own a farm and we
only have eleven thousand dollars in the
bank yes exactly exactly
that doesn't seem that doesn't seem okay
no I think being a farmer is really hard
I'm gonna be honest and we've already
spent eight dollars running a vehicle
and we haven't even moved I know oh wait
we can go can we go to the side here how
do we get oh here we go
whoo look at this fruit fruit I'm sure
oh that's your thing beets yeah where
the zombies Michael's way there's no
zombies it's farming simulator it's not
a zombie simulator it turns into a
horror game
hello Cove skate how about that Game of
Thrones episode mind blown I don't I
didn't watch it yeah didn't see it
didn't see it I want to get my roommates
not caught up and won't let me watch
Game of Thrones didn't Sid the [ __ ] are
you you know what I'm just gonna let's
just get into this let's just get into
this year all right well I'm gonna keep
hitting that is there sprint
other is here we go uh-oh one is sprint
l1 is spread yeah we'll trade off deaths
I don't know how you died I don't know I
don't know how it happens there's so
much information look if there's a ton
of time I'm bonding am on the top right
this is the most no hands mingles one I
agree no hands disappointed I want to
see like a farmer like Newark Turner all
right but how do we get in this vehicle
it's here we go all right we're in it
press acts to attach the header
attach ego babe this is great oh man I'm
a natural farmer I turn out of the
harvester oh what's that oh that little
thing went up
oh wait here we go Oh No there we go
yeah yeah let's get some driving
here we go let's do it oh yeah oh hey if
you press right stick
I don't know I'm the ghost of a farmer
oh wait cane they did why don't they
call this ghost yeah they should that's
a great wait you can see me here you can
see me here right to a hug every eyeball
eyeball I think I bought balls in my
head
wait who laughs to your joke slumber
Thunder Jesus
no no I've already ruined the game I
think
yeah here we go this is how you do it
right let's get a little creative so
inefficient but you know why won't you
let it be a terrible part where you need
to know how to live man let's do a crop
circle all right wait can you make a
chain and you have a larger field with
crops because
no way turn off the harvester and drive
to the question mark next to trailer
all that
yeah I know it's pretty I gotta say this
is the graphics are pretty great that
week
people are it's a little loud
alright here's the trailer oh you know
cuz we got to get our wheat in the
trailer rip the harvest I think alike
draw some penises
alright you know what I'm gonna wait
till there's a bigger field Stephen is
better drawing than me so I'm gonna let
him do the thing yo trash that tractor
can you take it can you take it down a
notch oh yeah I can't I don't know if I
want to do that though how are we gonna
get the wheat to market wait I deploy
the pipe yeah that's what she said about
deploying the plate no no oh no whoops I
think you messed know anyway wait wait
I'll get it in there I'll get in there
there we go
got it nailed it that's pretty cool
that's great I could see this gate being
really fun it is really fun I'm having a
blast
exit the harvester I'm out of harvester
yeah let's get this tractor perfect for
you bet you don't like leaving the house
that's the trailer to the tractor gorica
not proud you know what you got to move
the the heart oh no no yeah yeah just
use some good old fence this is how it's
done right bump and jump yeah I'm gonna
do it yellow bump a Jim it tells me the
miles per hour I'm going which is nine
which is only Oh what's this where you
buy all your machine oh no it's not tell
the farmer I said hi please hello
thought this is our Amish farming
simulator no Michaels you couldn't have
an Amish farm you simulator because
because the Amish don't farm yes you
could no because it's a uses electricity
doesn't make any sense because they sent
it to us and it's awesome and I wouldn't
you want to play a game called farming
simulator they sent us to look at the
box where's the box oh I dropped it oh
the box right here yeah look at this is
a great this is great who wouldn't want
to play this game this is great and
thank you focus entertainment for
sending us this game you guys rule you
guys are the best and I must say you
have made a game that is incredibly
detailed and rich with colors and life
how do I get probably ax
yeah very a brief journey take that to
the weight plate I have a problem here
I'm not reading any of the things no you
just didn't how are you like harvested
no wheat
well isn't it tutorial this isn't the
tutorial it's just a guided tour oh wait
should we harvest more wheat yeah
because you need to make the bar you
harvest I've done my hardest
don't let artists uh Tim Jared no we're
not sponsoring them we just thought it'd
be a fun game to play uh let's get all
the wheat in the field have you asked me
to again questions here yes you can yes
Lou lafawn ask away
I get in there man you know what you
might want to clean up what I did there
I think I kind of put the pipe away dude
oh yeah think you got your pipe out how
do you pal so you hold l1 pipe in and
they tells you what to do I'm there so L
1 and then triangle well don't wanted it
there you go I almost just pipe tweet
all over the week idiot dumbass jack
reacher 12 I wish I had a real farm too
high one day and this is not a joke I
would like to have a real farm it'd be
really fun
Pinguino in splatoon maybe next week
splatoon have you guys played it is it a
good way to say you're saying one day
you'd like to have a farm I'm pretty
sure a farm is something that like you
build over an entire career no no no I'm
a farmer you know years and years no
Bella my life plan is you're just gonna
go to a farmer be like a give me your
farm it's gonna bake you want me to show
you how to use it ya know ya know I'm
just gonna hire him to farm for me oh
it's like a restaurant I don't know how
to how to how to run a restaurant but
like I liked it owned a restaurant and
then have someone run it for me ok
that's reasonable yeah I just like to
hang out on a phone oh how frequent that
happens I don't think it ever happens
slumber Thunder red shirt was born his
name's Steven by the way it was born
with her red shirt thank you that's
right
yes that red shirt is in these Native
American name red shirt okay why is all
that week coming out of the back of the
tracker don't you need that that's
Raptor that's the left over that's the
chaff yeah the check oh oh you're not
doing a good job either yeah you got
real boring yeah I know that's but you
can do a crease control I think how do
you do that I think it's I saw it
earlier I think it's r1 l1 and then
square it's what this game is like
Madden by the way it's so complicated
it's working oh yeah yeah word cruise
control control yeah it's kind of
crooked though I think you're gonna
start yeah you're missing you're missing
the part of the thing yeah do you think
farmers want to live in a 12 story
apartment building like The Sims ooh
I don't maybe you could build a 12 sir
oh my god if you could build your
farmhouse that'd be like that's fine I
bet you can a reason to farm in this
game exactly where Eddie Albert and
Jascha nephew like exactly I was never a
big Green Acres fan I'd also like to own
a pig by the way Oh
within the year yeah actually here's
something kind of cool they should we
kind of have we have animals sometimes
with my phone
we have animals sometimes come to the
show obviously they come on the show and
they brought eggs onto the show and one
of our the people here at the show ended
up buying a little baby pig and brings
the pig in ever so every so often
there's a little I was gonna have a
picture of this little tiny tiny pig
he's the one who's convinced me to buy
in there yeah it's amazing so here's the
photo of me and the little baby pig I
didn't see it there yeah that was taking
our hair and makeup department with that
cute little guy he's like smiling it's
so great so great I love little pigs Oh
get that pipe out hashtag pipe out is
that a bad hashtag yeah that's a hashtag
that might invite the FBI to
they already watch lifestyle wipes out a
knife so that's not a phrase I love it
yeah were you guys all what what
countries are we looking at today I saw
Poland earlier hello Poland Denmark ooh
Turkey awesome Oh Jack Reacher 12:00 I'm
planning on aquarion pig lair this year
we did a couple things with pigs and
here are some things about pigs I didn't
know we're solve pigs have a really hard
time walking up stairs they can't really
walk up stairs they're kind of a-holes
unless they're being fed pigs from
different the mobs will kill pigs from
other litters when they came all that we
had two litters of pigs and all the pigs
in one letter had blue on there one
other years because so they didn't get
put in the wrong litter because the mom
would kill them
so pigs are kind of crazy yeah
Philippines Finland Egypt what's up up
in the Egypt love Egypt like I have ps4
Egypt was a beautiful damn flatlander
doesn't know how to drive flatlander is
the Illinois country depends on where
you are be careful a car dude the crash
physics in this game are not realistic
that's good that's disappointing Rhode
Island captain Wiggum that is a separate
country where are you right now are you
going to a school do you got to go look
at the map wait where do I go on the map
you got to go it's a part of it I start
card in the distance I'll go to that you
want to go to that flashing circle okay
Switzerland Sweden Alabama pulling that
car I know I gotta say fred durst play
this game very well oh man we gotta have
thread back Fred and John carnage we're
super great that was a dream come true
way to really what that was a dream into
as big time Limp Bizkit fans this is
meant for mature audience now playing
farming simulator that's right this is
NSFW farming simulator mofos do you
think
look at these if you just added a little
bit of violence to this game would be a
perfect game dude make a mod lets make a
mod somebody make a mod for farming
simulator a mod must exist called body
farming like corpses see what was the
name of the game that we played last
time the zombie one Oh state of decay
state of decay mix that this would be a
state of decay but you have to keep a
farm going that would be awesome
like that'd be oh so these are all lots
where we can plant crowd yeah we're
going to if you'd ever drop the weed off
and you can make some money cow
mutilation farming simulator that's
pretty funny yeah dude you're going to
the sweet 26 miles an hour I think it
has your gas on that like top speed Oh
what's got a real funny if it ran out of
gas yeah no look at you see down there
like on the right I think it's I think
you can run out again what is that
what's the orange bar you know I'm gonna
look in the instructions that's gas drop
that weed off yeah well guessing where's
the weed boys whoo this is awesome or
you can oh you have to purchase a field
who we can hire some workers you're I
just got really big where's my stash yet
dab gold farmer get the turbo boost
decayed farm yeah farm of decay that's a
great name I'm gonna talk yeah now there
should be a question oh there yeah there
you go the ramp let's drive up that
right you can't run it I guess oh yeah
we're at 98 right now oh I see how this
works making money okay yeah hit X you
can check the current prices of all
products wow this game is super intense
this game is really intense as one of
the places on the map where you can sell
your harvest this is look how big this
book is see top of the pit seems almost
a little tears on the side
alright let's just get it centered over
the pit yeah
and then the next oh yeah unloaded ah
hashtag pipe out hashtag - how much cash
how much cash uh I don't hit the thing
giggles how much cash do we get whoa
whoa whoa whoa I got $15,000 oh yeah
four thousand ein this is cool
yeah shady fridge I know they took they
took this seriously what are you doing
now
whoa that thing looks they should yeah
they should definitely make a farming
simulator our DK is great like a zombie
neighbor hashtag pipe out you're feeling
me Tim jr. finally uh I don't know man
no switch until you see the one next to
the question Mario where we're left and
right left and right no no that one
cultivating we're gonna cultivate a
field finally Steven someone's asking
what you would name your farm candy for
it that's pretty good name I would name
mine candy for us to just change mine to
a deep blue sea after my favorite movie
oh yeah I guess mine would be yeah deep
blue sea is it good there's so many now
lower the cultivator and drive over the
field the cultivated soil okay do it
then hit X oh yeah hit X dude I want to
see the field being cultivated you
didn't lower the implement there we go
yeah yeah get in there ah god you're
cultivating the [ __ ] out of that field
what are you doing we don't have any
workers are you just gonna ghost ride
the whip okay it's gonna jump out you're
gonna ghost ride your tractor worker
hired now let's see how this works okay
so it just keeps happening and a worker
takes care cultivate in the field while
I go manage some other business is that
we did are they cultivating it yeah oh
that's great that's easy
oh man we really learned a lot about
business spread that dirt Cody the
dragon dude you know what I'm talking
about what is he doing let's see okay is
he just doing you actually see how yeah
wait this is him this is our worker yeah
we're evaluating job performance right
now Oh see he lowers the implement as
soon as he gets out of the field so he
doesn't ruin the implement when he's off
of it what is this guy's name Jim Jim
from quimbo Jimbo yeah it's Liz and Jim
but we've hired Jim Belushi there's
between projects right now after the
defenders went off the air to cultivate
our field that's great maybe you know
what they should have a show any TV
execs watching and I know you guys are
watching a show celebrity farmer yeah
where they give a celebrity complete
yeah yeah and for a month oh yeah and
and that farm is the only source of food
for a town so the people will starve
because you gotta have steaks yeah I
think that's important I'd like to talk
for a moment about vehicles and
implements of which there is a large
section in this book okay let's go
through everybody name their favorite
vehicle and implement now first of all
hear me out
you got your tractors you got your front
loaders your plows your cultivators your
sewing machines then we get into stuff
like combine harvesters I like a good
combine Baylor's mowers Tedder Tedder's
Tedder's the Tedder we got to get a roto
Tedder looks pretty dope a wind rower a
forage wagon
and then potatoes that's not an
implement or a thing cattle management's
[Music]
game over cattle management damn I like
hoes you know what I gotta say it's been
22 minutes
jet lag you are the first person to make
a hoe joke
well done okay
well I'm giving props I'm giving props a
jet lag jet lag well done chat high-five
shall I put your hand up to the screen
right over the thing ready one two three
high five we did it we did it through
the internet oh it's not how you use
this thing no I'm about to find out what
this thing is it looks pretty cool
you're waiting for the perfect moment
jet lag and you found it
gary busey st farmer deep blue sea yes
that would be one of my favorite jokes
ever made
we enter the tractor attempt deep blue
seas well done yeah what should we do
filling this no now we're sewing a field
oh my god sorry [ __ ] oh this is putting
seeds on down okay
why don't they just call it that see it
machine color seeds and seeds next to
the seeds in seed machine okay do I mess
with hose no I'm a terrible farmer
obviously got you where do these seeds
come you can buy trucks in this game Tim
jr. said uh when you're close enough you
could start filling your sewing machine
when close to seed pallets oh okay oh
you're filling it up oh there we go Oh
see the white bar on the right ah there
you go
600 600 one machine yeah this is still
wheat I think right well done now drive
to the field which is marked by a green
flag right field 24 this game is so
complicated now dude I could see myself
getting real into this
I mean I'm into it it just really
compacted you don't know what I don't
know what the Oh Deb Gold says grow some
cheeseburgers that's a good idea
you know what I'm choosing the name to
my farm - cheeseburger farm cheeseburger
farm I
it's kind of depressing for the cows
it's a race course from the new Mario
cheeseburger
it should be a new unlockable track
Mario Kart jack reacher slippery
something on farms anyway let's choose
steve zahn as a farm that's right
look at this mess of a harvesting that
looks like a bad haircut I'm gonna leave
that there so we always remember where
we came exactly and how far we've gone
oh yeah you taking that turn kind of
tight eh
all right bananas please I don't think
we can grow bananas fine horn sweet
beets Beth legsweep yeah lay down some
sweet beets you're not gonna make any
money on the piece no you know what wait
wait let's check wait wait hit hit left
stick oh yeah yeah let's check the
prices all right wait we get on sheep oh
here we go here we go sugar beets
17400 it's a storage look no price for
sugar beets because nobody wants to buy
them wait what yes there is 678 purty
oh yeah that's do we want it condolence
what we want canola canola it looks a
little flower alright cuz it probably is
a flower canola
no no get down on that there we go
canola change that up to canola although
it seems uh-oh hit next hit ax what are
you doing hit ax hit ax we don't have
the machine said X please hit X I'm
trying to so figure out how to select
the dang
hold on l1 it's up there in the corner
okay that's canola right
yeah that's canola cool seat it oh we're
gonna make so much Bank well now I don't
have any of that Knight oh okay here's
how we lower we now we lower the
implement with you I Drive up to that
guy
I think he's supposed to lower something
we haven't sold anything last pointer so
good fine all right finally we're done
with the tour no I got a I got a sow
some seeds what are the things on the
side do those are sewing implements that
how do they sell oh there we go
I think you're just dumping a bunch of
weight try wait you got I don't you know
the seats are coming out man
Oh are they I don't know you made me
close the dang instructional window for
no roll hold l1 hold that one all right
lower so er oh oh oh you selected the
wrong seed man we're off the canola seed
ah geez this farms going under is it
what steaks are hot yeah you're doing it
Wiley concedes yet yeah yep the seeds
are going down cool so all right ooh
look at that
hired me a worker thank God this guy
doing sell your land we just got our
land printed Joker this guy's making
some good progress oh yeah there we go
this guy's all right let's switch to a
different machine let's get something
else going if this is a real farm losing
guard you'd all be fired for wasting
pressure field music garden you worked
in a farm who in the chat has worked on
a farm if you worked at a farm speak up
for God's sakes we need some help all
this canola Charlie work if you die in
this game you die in real life yes those
are the stakes that's the focus
entertainment is creative we all had to
put up this computer microchip you put
in and it matters you like an escape
from New York thank you these are
expensive well yeah man I want that one
does
oh the old scorpion sowe're I feel like
these ones are like dr. hexapla pulled
weed by hand in a tree farm wasn't it
just a forest whoa Forrest farmville
doesn't count dark the Sookie telling
you don't buy what are you buying
you don't need a semi how many cool
trucks is that old jet ski
that's what I thought okay so what are
we doing some hydroponic yeah boy all
right wait end of the tour look for more
question marks all right so let's look
for some more questions
oh you know what I see I see a couple
people that need to get run over right
track I can't you can't run but I can't
are there people in this game oh there
we go
all right yeah what's that to jump the
biomass heating whoa ooh dude let's get
out some trees wood chips yeah money
hashtag pipe out man
you know I'm talking about pipe out to
go get some wood you know pipes pipe out
and get some wood they're all around you
bro you got to get a tree cutter downer
I think it's what they you know let me
look at the book pretty sure it's a tree
cutter downer
I'm scared somebody said you should be
scared
hashtag pipe out or a hashtag pipe in I
guess if you're scared all right I think
you're gonna want a also I think it's
simple we're gonna want to get some
cattle wait oh dude I want to get well
first let's get some wood all right all
right here what about this is a plan B
cut down some trees we get the biomass
heating plant going who is that a circus
yeah that's what I was just thinking
maybe we just check out the circus tree
harvest or maybe that house it'd be oh
yeah maybe they're making bet they're
like spoiler alert Breaking Bad pipe
middle you're feeling me red bull roids
want to see some chickens
oh my hashtag bleep Stephen yeah but I'm
not running the controls this time oh
you have to manly cut down trees with a
chain side we said that thank you for
saying that my god dude go get a
chainsaw I gotta change
dude yeah using a change that has a
cost-efficient way of cutting out trees
how do we is this a trailer park on our
property well there's like cart easier
this is a carny Wow
oh no how far can you travel out using
great said start your own animal but it
goes like infinite it's like a big-ass
place this is awesome it's infinite wait
oh my go back to the wait wait can you
from this menu get a chainsaw yeah how
do you Dolly's head her trailers r1 or
l1 try going over to this side
no branch okay well I know all the
brands somebody's gonna pick my favorite
this is a whole new world that's crazy
these real yeah I think everything's
like super accurate that's the point get
a cheese up your local circus oh good
that's not a bad idea actually I think
from the guy juggling chainsaws this
game could use those some music yeah I
like the music from the Sims
yeah wait what's the music when this is
pretty much what you just read yeah sooo
carcass says you have to cut off your
hand and attach it to your stump like
army darkness style that's not true
little ash I'm not sure that having it
losing a hand is going to be a efficient
way we are moving in this thing by the
way do we have a chainsaw ready you're
good are you going straight to the water
on the hop it we're gonna die we're
gonna do uh oh no we lost the tractor
guys it's already like
look at the people over here oh yeah go
talk to some people maybe they can help
you push out your tracker Lord
hey can you help me and then hey it
doesn't look like a farmer at all yeah
it's like they're all creepy Ballmer
talk to you it's all full of Jordans
Lansky's just a world of the exact same
walk cycle to take over I was gonna try
to find the chainsaw
yeah that's hey hey what's up how's it
going yeah look at this creepy walk this
is like how aliens think humans walk
yeah yeah oh here's hotel first year 3d
animation student walks I clean
interesting well there's railings here I
don't see a wheelchair ramp an
accessible ramp so uh that's a code
violation I feel like maybe this door is
just painted on how do we switch to the
other tractors see how your workers are
you can I get one of these cars
oh you can't that stinks did you already
try yeah ah I'm just a mirror I'm just a
farmer I can't drive a real car
I'm a ghost yeah I'm just a ghost farmer
oh meteor strike uh use the d-pad left
right am i walking on water and my Jesus
farmer no you're a ghost I'm a ghost far
what am i just do freelance work at my
house all day yeah exactly
we're gonna start we're gonna start at
twitch from my house which will be fun
oh yeah but I haven't got the delay
situation down yet but once I do maybe
next weekend maybe this maybe this
weekend we'll do some twitching from
place place it'll be horrifying I need
to do a little clean
yeah please place it's in Comic Sans is
Rainwood crap yeah that's right
crappy bar known as my life how do I get
here see if you can figure out how to
get the chainsaw this is cool duh oh
it's good they leave a couple of pages
for notes yeah just to take that
everything is GTA farmer how do you I
like I prefer this this is in French
it's in French
yeah you're in the French section
there's a dating site performance it's
called farmers only
someone said reset the tractor from Mac
it will be I'm gonna call somebody to
buy a chainsaw all using a chainsaw as a
cost-effective way someone set a shop oh
oh oh oh just go down to find basic
workflow wood oh yeah that's gonna we
can make milk grass and hay forestry new
trees just pop ourselves okay duh duh
yep yep yeah I know that it doesn't tell
me anything easy as the sugar pee of
course oh my god a cheaper alternative
is to use a tractor several specialized
tools this basically works in two steps
first have to cut the foliage with a
column topper like the grim KS 77 5-4 of
course after that you can get the crop
out of the ground by using a harvester
like the grim estimate 260 dog I was
gonna say that 265 but I mean I guess
the 260 if you just want to start things
this is crazy
I kind of feel like you know what's kind
of cool about this vehicle shop that's
where they said the chainsaw oh really
you don't think I see really cool what
this game is like I feel like I don't
have any skills like when the apocalypse
comes you know but I think learning
about farming this could actually teach
you about farming to the point where
maybe
well there's looking at me like now they
do know they do use this like farmers
kids play the [ __ ] out of it I'm sure
yeah I mean this is great all right hold
on vehicle selection
animals cows owns zero we're gonna
change that in a minute
whoo manure we only let's see what our
manure is dollars
I just want to get a chainsaw here hold
on uh chainsaw
I don't we freakin eggs pieces of eggs
this triangle price triangle that's just
the regular store like a I don't I don't
it didn't it didn't look like you can
just go willy-nilly chop down any tree
it's not like you had to plan some aah
plant withering plant growth fast we're
gonna make this fast can you go extra
fast time skill whew should we go crazy
time no no that's gonna be terrible
five times no missions plant growth
plant withering is great all right we do
it's on you know what you need to learn
a hard lesson about life plants wither
and die that's what happens where am I
going here looking crouched why why can
I crouch why can you crouch in this game
- from enemies whoa look at all this
crap to do all right
where should I go here go to the two
workers you have working oh wait there's
cows I see cows okay wait
all right hold on wait that way point uh
no I'm just gonna do this there we go
here's no one worker he's doing great
look at those straight rows pretty great
and then no here's our other guy oh oh
oh he's on it how - yeah I know he's a
guy oh yeah fine fine fine fine
he was turning the tractor checking
Instagram is what he's doing I'm not
gonna dismiss him he's doing a good job
okay
[Music]
how do we go towards that cow we're that
cow Viet it's a it's down and to your
left so yeah sorry gonna take a right
take a right go back this way right take
a right this way
yes that is your right
like I should just go across that feel
like a quarter of a mile this way yeah
now we're doing it Cirque de farm
vehicle shop is this a clip we're doing
it
[Laughter]
drunk farming simulator would give me
some of that corn alcohol oh yeah dude
extreme farming this is what I'm talking
about guys hashtag pipe out crazy
whoa and I got I got a what oh my God
look at it
oh I done hit a tree wait wait a second
wait wait wait maybe we should try to
cut down one of these trees do we maybe
we just have the chainsaw that's one
thing about this game they should just
give you a chainsaw a brand name it is
oh really Jones I'm gonna get out I want
it laser whoops you know what's
interesting this is a farming simulator
but you have total control over time and
space you can just like teleport it's
pretty great all right no wait how do I
get to the shop why there's no y so
there you go no goddamn why change
vehicle for you try this oh my god this
is insane
this is insane all right why here we go
okay what was it again it was John's red
yes thank you for your purchase great
how do I do it let's try angle there it
is press press
oh no that's to sell it go back get out
of here get out of this man get out of
the track
power that chainsaw yeah activate head
tool yeah I knew it you have to plant
nope nope I don't believe you
wait I need to rotate it yeah
now what's up give it to me here get
either yes oh man hashtag serious pipe
out is happening right now I've got a
timber trophy greatest day in my life I
don't know why it's not falling down
though oh no I know it's not my tractor
alright harvest it oh crap
now you got a harvest it bleh don't know
how to do that yeah I know not wait now
you just cut it up yeah I'll look at me
cutting this thing up this is great a
long time to get through that one off
camera action it oh yeah oh dude we just
gotta chop it up this is awesome here
you want your chop it up chop it all up
undo I use l1 l1 and there are the
triggers yeah this is great oh this game
is awesome oh my god we got a free
Archer I mean I will say I'm it made me
sad that it went on tonight
of course I cut down a tree and it falls
on the tractors I'm an idiot oh dude
this is great look at this you can see
the Rings Oh monkey say wait a second
monkey says small chunks mean less money
well you know what this is just our
first tree yeah I don't know jump riddle
me that
whoa yeah I said name your thing how do
we get it back in the thing I think you
need special tools now that you have a
chainsaw go find those creepy creepy
yeah maybe we should go try to kill I
mean I think it's gonna be imagine if
you could kill people this yeah there
you go cut
yeah we're terrorizing everybody yeah
this is exactly kind of notch on one
side oh my god wait wait toasted teddy
bears cuts down trees every day cut a
notch in one side of base of tree then
back down then back cut the other side I
cut trees down every day that's really
cool thank you toasted teddy bear all
right so wait wait do it he said cut so
cut a notch all right back out back out
all right now now to cut the other side
nope
I think he meant the other side he got
to rotate the other way I know I was
just making sure the notch was good the
other way
Wow thank you for the tip touch teddy
bear it's nice to know that there's
someone in the chat who's actually cuts
down trees oh there we go
that worked awesome I know maybe cut
into big pieces
Oh Gemma says we need to buy the trailer
with the claw you're right we got to go
back to show the clock all right which
one's the trailer with the clock
I don't see it what's that you can use a
front loader Oh front loaders right
there on the Left we want the cloth oh
yeah okay let me see what the clothes
called this game is awesome by the way
all right chop the roadside I like it
alright see are there more things to the
right Genesis last time I weighed
something slumbered Thunder what
happened when you went to the woods with
your chainsaw
we want a tree Harvester and I think
it's made by my god
good lord hmm we're stumped cutter cut
down trees kind of stuff do you move
this truck partner ah you find it is it
one of these you can't afford the claw
man we're gonna all right
can we hook it up to our tractor fetch
my purchase of the store well no no I
think if you just get into the thing I
think even hooked up in the back or no
you got to gosh we physically maybe we
should cut this up and move the tree out
of the road I disagree I think everybody
is hating our farm because we haven't
we're just all we've done is blocked the
road with trees let's go get some cows
yeah but they're gonna have some sugar
beets and Moo cows it's true
plus it's pretty cool that they I get to
have the world's first extreme farmer
yeah it's pretty great this is like
x-games way to farming
look at this I wouldn't go in there
middle of the woods
can you attach it to your tractor and
drag it around
we're running out of money we're running
out of money oh yeah - we're running out
of money
gotta go sell some crops yeah let's go
harvest some wheat wait all right
what Musha all right you guys tell us
what plant we should plant next i think
there's sugar beets wheat we just
planted canola all right so we'll go
let's go harvest the canola
oh yeah we grow well you know we have a
field of wheat
let's go harvest the wheat okay time has
to be out normal while you're driving or
else you lose a hundred dollars a minute
oh Jesus how about a second the tube
again I'll pipe in l1 triangle yeah I
think we need to maybe harvest this feel
a little better you got to put the thing
down man l1 square
I'd be at work here for this one yeah
he's like these guys work cut out this
we can afford to pay more people yeah
exactly
we're terrible oh my god I guess you got
that guy working over there you got you
got he doesn't even know what did to it
was like how does this even work
marijuana grow marijuana yes yes yes ah
Jack Klugman this is Bjorn home does it
freaking look like Westbridge us a nose
like Bjorn whoa it looks like effing
Buuren home ever started the corner Oh
start at the corner and hire the worker
okay say Jemma said yeah otherwise I
think we're just wasting money just
driving around with every last dock is a
program to algorithm you know we should
do perfectly and you know you gotta do
man you gotta let's drag a trailer back
over there so that he can dump it out
because he's not gonna be able to keep
going unless the trailers over there
throw some Kush Goblin yes thank you God
Oh gross to me cuz I'm good one question
egg obvious good yeah get some dab dab
dab that's right that's right
is it organics real Kevin yeah that's
actually sir Oh chemist makes a good
point can we do something organic
how are the bugs not getting every
spraying these crops in what kind of
spray we're gonna use we don't even have
any crops yet well we're going to lie
get ahead of ourselves
hashtag well played some of the slumber
Thunder yeah I'm sure it is it's gonna
be like 50 cars long and people just
walking like yeah and what do we do
Zachry the tree in the way I'm just
joining us welcome we're playing farming
simulator 15 today by the amazing focus
home entertainment
it's a ash
phenomenal game we're having a good time
Beth Marat skis in the chatroom Steven
Smith is this is last Monday melee which
were sad about I think Chris Weller over
here on the ones and twos and O'Malley
the creepers left the room okay see what
that board is see what the message board
is maybe there's like a Craigslist ad
for a couch I feel like we probably need
a couch farmer need a couch - hello a
cannery on Switzerland good to see ya
you ever been to Bjorn home yeah Bjorn
home there's nothing no there there's
nothing really play daddy somebody said
they should make a farming simulator
2115 that would be awesome old soldiers
Maya nanobots yeah you're harvesting the
moon all right are you like killing
somebody yeah
assassination missions fascination
machines I would read the notice board
pretty well that's where we differ shady
fridge that's where we differ we shoot
from the hip garage sale simulator it's
also called
that's right oh god oh god
good lord Bjorn ho man that's right
where where how do we know where the
wheat field is we're we paying attention
we can check the map this fella is by
field 29 build 29 see like he's just
waiting for us no he was turning it
around how did you
now oh he's off-grid he's off the grid
he's lost his mind we got to stop hiring
these workers to do all these drugs how
did I lose all that weight I eat really
healthy and work out that's what you got
to do man there's no way around it
adding a lot of self-loathing the
self-loathing diet it's fantastic
Euro Truck Simulator my god I know I've
never been to South uh I've been to
South Florida what's the South Florida
Orlando
that's a South Floyd area Daytona Beach
I've been to those places South Florida
this guy is just you now yeah would you
dismiss a worker yeah you fired someone
so he won't be able to feed his family
because he actually just abandoned Diddy
we need to seriously start selling some
more wheat well is this guy done this
fellow's done look at that they're all
done we still need to sell the wheat
hire a worker is very efficient
harvesting yeah we went back to what was
it field 29 yeah I don't I think you got
to go up and drop the map
open real good I think L 1 and then the
still god of Jesus oh one and then
distinct left stick there yeah we want
to go oh there it is it tells you where
the oh no no field 29 ok we're on the
right track
yeah yeah you just want to go look we
haven't even explored anything Lockett
lawless
we're not signed in right now too but
maybe we should do of a multiplayer oh
yeah I mean it would be boring for us to
sign in yeah they should the race in 22
they should give you the option to hire
a robot that would be awesome and then
every like 4th robot goes crazy and you
have to like destroy them and then
gather an army of robots and fight
Ultron and then Thor shows up and the
other guy can lift the hammer and people
get upset about Black Widow it's the
whole thing that's right
and what age of ultron majors I liked it
I did was fun to watch a lot of cool
battle scenes Locke and lawless no
please
totally fine to ask and and and I find
known before I started this game up that
it was multiplayer we would have signed
in so and maybe we will in a future
future stream because we had a really
fun time playing battlefield hardline in
the guys
oh there that guy is there he is all
sweet remember fishing simulator yes
Conan is shooting something today so he
can't come by I'm sorry but we do have
the next best thing
no don't do it the next best thing here
it goes hey everybody just even hate so
I do this it wouldn't be your last
stream fight I didn't think it'd ever
saw that he would actually oh I'm so sad
you're leaving give me a kiss kiss me
Stephen don't
what's wrong there might not be nothing
today
what's the problem peridot yeah I'd like
to put in my two minutes my two minute
notice exactly
get out of here worker so yeah pipe it
out dude fight hashtag pipe out pipes
that nice tile I've said nice sound
always say pipe so nice sound a lot of
farmers say yeah uh are fgh I asked
Jordan every week if he wants to come by
whoo look at that wheat that's kind of
great actually I gotta say sweet sweet
wheat maybe we do a couple runs of wheat
and then take it so it's like it in are
things full so we definitely get a lot
of money yeah what happens if you go
bankrupt oh oh wait somebody said if you
drive wait next to the worker with the
pipe out they'll it'll just go the pipe
will go straight in okay you don't have
say no no no no put the pipe out I think
while he's driving
it'll fill up yeah but then I got a I
guess that makes sense yeah then you can
fill up the whole thing it's more more
efficient
like it
yeah but you know you got it but no but
when I hashtag pipes out haha
Red Bull roids hashtag pipe out straight
in oh yeah there's a lot of sexual
frustration in this game when I hire a
worker he puts the pipe back in so that
person was oh oh they didn't know
anything about it oh that sucks
alright so where do we sell the weed
again the worker will automatically pipe
out if you put if you go next in with
the trailer Oh Auto pipe out oh this is
so great I'm learning so much this is
awesome I gotta say I was a little
skeptical about this game being fun but
I'm high this is a game I would
definitely play it's great look at him
team me dying or yeah do it it's like a
Michael Bay Phil yeah oh yeah keep
driving man no no he stops the thing and
uh that's very cool awesome oh you
already much he says you already have
ten thousand and each crop stocked in
the silo at your farm where's the silo I
don't know let's just go sell a bunch of
stuff man get that bling-bling pretty
junk or where the explosions I don't
know yet but I'm hoping at the biomass
plant let me do a lot of wood chipping
we've got our mission before this is
done is to clear that stupid tree we I
cut down in the middle of the road bags
okay so once we do this we got to buy
the big arm thing I want to see that
aren't at work
okay well this and then we can see if we
can pick up the people with them like oh
we like a robot dinosaur and crush them
dish crush then the best the people
exactly yeah yeah these look like Silas
well let's should we go sell this first
we don't want to mix and match right
well maybe there's a bunch of wheat in
the silo we don't have any
what happens when we run out of money
are we just like done oh here we go
oh here we go so it's a pretty straight
around but we want to sell we don't want
a store to retrieve a commodity for
interested okay I see okay oh yes you're
gonna get a bunch of you load that [ __ ]
up make some load it up load it up load
it up Kellogg's Jordan would hate this
game
alright here we go pipe out o start
filling yeah fill hashtag fill porn
that's good stuff oh hell yeah boy take
fill port tank filled four that's
there's farmers out there yeah Oh
straight into the trailer and a hot week
okay so where's the unloader oh it's the
thing that looks like a stapler stapler
uh yeah Green elevators ah green
elevators that's where you want to go
right poor company shipping office
lumberyard no no garden centre now I
think that's what it is
I think green elevator we've been
hanging around a lot in the lower right
we're wandering so straight and then
left the way they have the map set up is
not so they're differently as you could
sell it pricing is different though what
we're just gonna go to the one yeah it
would be cool to put your hand in there
oh man
blame the trip wait oh yeah yeah get it
get it cut that it cut it down
it's like life you know completed it's
like life it ends when you die you as a
human being on this earth is when this
game ends yeah that's it it's the stakes
are high man you are working to cut down
trees and right on the trip yup right on
the track right another we really got to
start going around the other side we cut
down these trees merica Felix young
gaming you know I'm talking Uncas Dylan
yes sir carcass we showed that tree who
is boss we're the tree boss it's like
cake possible with trees every season is
just watching one tree grow it's imagine
somebody making a cake and it's that and
then and then they drive it around
there's ago we shouldn't have put it in
the car with the frosting on it cakes
just literally a direct rip I'm een I
don't know which came first the chicken
or the cake boss you're going the wrong
way
you want to go right love Cake Boss it's
like porn yeah same with this farming
boss we're like a farm boss more like a
harming boss okay sorry
straw boss I need to pick up the tree I
know worked the whole point is we're
trying to get right now money so we can
buy them that's it a tree picker-upper
which is the proper name I know it's
called something else and a see lead
seven B - four six five bless you all
right here we go why did they come
here's an actual real question all this
stuff is so cool why don't they come up
with cooler names for this stuff
like for instance no they're not cool
like look at this thing wait a second
look at this thing wait a sec it is the
first time we unloaded wheat we had like
maybe a cord
a tank yeah yeah and we got $15,000 yeah
then we got three we just got $3,000 we
had them talk about my like for instance
like this thing like like like it's an
okay automatic bail loader okay you see
that right there
automatic bail loader right there you
see it I don't know okay
now this thing that's the most boring
name ever automatic bail letters yes
descriptive it's descriptive but it's
not cool call it like I don't know like
laser
Mirage machines no but that's the point
like cars are need different things
right like like yeah but cars are just
to buy and look at Jaguar that's a cool
fine the Foreman's function you know
it's like it is one thing but you know
you gotta have a little style just
calling it a scorpion would make farming
more fun yeah I do
you called that one thing a scorpion and
you wanted to buy it because you said it
look like a scorpion so call it a
scorpion like that's why P that's why
people pay more for Apple products
because it's aesthetically pleasing you
know make everything cool and weird and
rounded Hobson's why the Steve Jobs of
farming do you understand get on my
level hashtag get on my farming level
that's right man farm boss 2015 do we
have enough money yet for this thing on
orders getting more wheat but I'm just
saying like John Deere like stop making
all your crap you're sorry you're great
products like like like green and yellow
like I get it's a brand but like make it
cool put some chrome on there may I get
a little neon going you know I'm saying
like how cool would it be to have a
tractor that looked like the back of the
Future DeLorean I would buy that tractor
in a second your hash to you you're
tilling a field that looks like it looks
like it looks like a back the future
thing or what about like a big robot it
looks like a big robots walking way I
disagree I think all the stuff has been
like designed for perfect function
like you get food make it look like a
big insect you know no I listen to Steve
Jobs and then finally people assistive
jobs and one day people listen to me
about farming equipment no I'm not drunk
I'm worked up I'm worked up about this
farming situation we're all farmers can
[ __ ] about farmers can have fun I
love how Steve is so friend guys don't
get it get on my level get out my
farming level you guys dude look at all
those fish eggs yeah now yeah these fish
eggs
yeah it's caviar and there's a salmon
Batmobile c ZX oden h9 3 is feeling me
yeah that mobile tractor 0 h9 3 oh they
had the opportunity to name his own
screen name like something cool yeah
anyone with zxo 8 9 3 exactly so you're
the ones I all you want on your side
exactly alright maybe they maybe they
just did was the maybe they they just
fell on the keyboard or something while
they're having their thing yeah they
should let you put flames other custom
decals on there I agree you guys are
feeling me you guys are feeling me on
this make it very well like Need for
Speed under great yeah like fast and
furious farming yes 3x I wanna see what
Vin Diesel's trap yeah Furious 8 I want
to see like tractors and [ __ ] that would
be awesome that would be awesome
having had tractors they should get like
an automatic Bale loader like with a
spoiler honey will be joke that would be
dose a rage play yeah a hashtag rage
play I'm very worked you guys don't
understand how it worked up I'm about
farming equipment I mean maybe you do
now B didn't before hell yeah what is
community another remote we're taping
another exciting video game thing on
Thursday but it's not gonna be out for
[Music]
attractor made of jelly now that's silly
that's gonna melt in the heat I'm not
trying to make jelly does make it
because jellies usually in a frozen
state yeah that will melt well I'm just
saying it's sticky and it's gonna
attract bugs I mean that's different
than like putting flames in your tractor
no no problems the fact that you just
probably can't make a tractor and a
jelly boy just yeah it's gonna be hard
so like look at those fuku bucks baby
yeah get in there
canola go get another load of canola mmm
we have enough to get I think we have
enough to get our machine now which how
do I do that
this here we go no wait we want to thank
naturally we purchased a front loader we
have we want we want like uh no no we
want like at the arm thing what's the
arm thing no no your baling technology
wait see we're getting close look at
this thing dude give me the honest AK FX
63 72 bro or as I call it the Otto stack
as I call it the lightning bug no it's I
call it the death spider that thing
should be called the death spider you
can't tell me it doesn't like I totally
would I pay double I don't know how well
it's the second page there's a little
arrow yeah but these are the two pages
get a wind rower don't you know what
once you mind your own goddamn business
mister no deafness what did I say spider
a tipper there's more than one page of
equipment I don't see it it's like oh
it's like category huh no there's not
more our one press are what happens when
you press r1
it goes to there is uh you know what
let's look at can you look up what the
the tree thing is the thing is there's a
second page here we go Pottinger now
we're into the real [ __ ] starts tire ooh
this looks Corre planter tree harvesters
who makes it who makes it yellow which
is everything maybe it's Karcher the
hell is this oh you can clean stuff
that's cool
uh nope look at this thing dude oh my
god this is swab Pro I'm gonna step up
to the bathroom real quick
all right ooh are these missiles okay I
don't I guess we have a front loader
right where's it at caterpillar
all right caterpillar then whoops wait
here we go caterpillar where's aren't
like deployed caterpillar out there's no
caterpillar here that's crazy
Scorpion King Harvester yeah is that we
want that's what is that we want for
forestry now see everyone to need it to
nyan right now is like you what are you
doing what are you guys doing
Oh pon pon see uh poncey pon see I don't
see it ponzi yellow bottom right oh oh
here it is this is great three score big
king yeah oh it's so expensive see they
named it something cool Ponson you're
doing it right Buffalo is okay six out
of ten but Scorpion King is a great name
for something oh I'm definitely all
right you know what more canola we're
selling everything wait can we go to the
bank let's go to the bank you know what
let's go to the bank and just take out a
huge loan I don't care this is not the
right way to do this where's the bank at
transportation companies shot biomass
plant lumberyard shipping office we got
to figure out how to get a loan
I need the Scorpion King bad scorpion I
need it let's look at the prices for
stuff in canola we're going back over to
some canola that's done that you can
only take out 200k that's okay is that
all we need no cuz they really have like
30 grand man how do I get rid of this
tell me once it it's next to the shop
sex this show ATM allows you to take
let's go to the ATM it's gonna be fun
it's next to the shop I see the shop
it's right there by the way farming
simulator be great to have a waypoint
situation here cuz it is hard
Jesus
we go I'm doing it
we're doing it got caught up over is
this working
Harden's this is harder than it looks
guys I'm just saying yeah more than one
speed what's up
we're doing it off-roading let's go
today they let it in it's like this is
like Skyrim but with tractors yeah it's
like tractor Skyrim its land rim here we
go take a little stroll if I was a
farmer I would do this every day just
drive the tractor through the fields
scare all the wildlife stop by my
friends pad it's a pretty nice house is
that true how do you drive a tractor
well there there what are some tractor
tips
hashtag tractor tips first off there's
no pedal you actually have a there's no
pedal there's no pedal there is a
there's a switch on the side that has a
picture of a turtle and a rabbit really
I'm dead serious
it's a Kubota tractor he just wah I'll
say you were to shift gears in a Chevy
exactly
oh my god that's hilarious you can
either go track and so you either go
rabbit speed or tortoise speed yep it's
a real sophisticated system interesting
how fast is rabbit speed it's about 20
miles an hour that's pretty fast it's
surprisingly quick that's awesome hi I'm
like lost in the woods here Jesus here
we go here we go here we go let's do it
let's do it stream track Turing I'm
supposed to go up going this way roof
they got were out of the woods but we're
not out of the woods yet I will sell
everything I own for the Scorpion King I
don't care
there we go I think she's the shop is
somewhere over here if I don't I'm
stakin oh I'm so far away from the shop
good somewhat then see will be gone too
long
yeah just left her in a car like driving
away zag uh listen chat if you guys
think the Buffalo is better I'll buy the
Buffalo you guys tell me what to do and
you guys know better than me it's not
some a rally game I know man I'm trying
to get to the shop to borrow some money
to get the Scorpion King or the Buffalo
to get the law to start doing logs and
chipping them to get the biomass plant
there's a plan man there's a trading
game Enzo yeah exactly go across the map
that's the whole thing alright here we
are at the bank we just arrived at the
bank Oh what are we getting at the back
I'm gonna take out a big loan so I could
buy the scorpion you know you don't even
know what you can do with the scorpion
thing yeah I think that's no that's what
you do yeah I mean that you get trees
with it we were looking it up oh really
I think so here we go money yeah what if
you don't qualify for the loan because
they're like oh you wasted $15,000 doing
nothing whoa sell your [ __ ] I don't want
to sell it though can I go to the ATM
oh wait this is where we pick up the bit
okay wait dude this is the this is the
front ler maybe let's just take the
front loader and yeah just it you need a
tractor there to get it bless you
why is their physical presence for the
shop when all you have to do is press
triangle to get to know a good oh wait
check finances yeah all right we've been
buying a lot of we already had a fifty
thousand dollar loan that we blew we're
18 grand and this is one day we wasted
50 grand
in one day we bought ten thousand
dollars borrow five thousand yes borrow
more oh look at all this grand hell yeah
all right well now just go buy the most
expensive machine no I want to go get
the scorpion yeah
this is great I love to know living all
right
all right I can't I can't cut the bank
give me more money all right here we go
let's put this away the bank I'll go to
that waterfall over there that's a cool
idea pretty stuff wait how do I get my
tractor back all right wait what was it
who is it made by again Ponzi dude see
they name their stuff cool things they
named it after the movie with the rock
you don't have enough money for the
Scorpion King no but I do have enough
money for the Buffalo is that a tree
tree sucker this can cut down trees yes
the transport tree locks definitely
don't have enough money for the Buffalo
oh wait I don't I only have $181,000 ah
all right now we gotta use a front
loader like you to sell your tractor now
forget it oh you're right your track boy
you're right let's do that
so sell everything we have a separate
one tractor and we got to get the
Scorpion kay-kay we need it uh hey PMS
Phoenix rain
thank you yes we have a twitch no it's
been sold yeah okay oh no keep the
cheats off these are the chugger all
right now go to poncey yes all right yes
yes yes
okay all right there oh yeah oh my god
yes oh that's a flag sorry third is
Twitter my tweet my twitter name is
snakes and rats snakes snakes and rats
don't use it
hardcore no I don't miss it here we go
oh dude just cut down some trees wait
let's go oh my god it's just awesome
where is the first victim
haha what this tree type is not
supportive [ __ ] this tree type is
not supported what do you mean that sons
of [ __ ] go back to where this tree
type is not supported but doesn't make
any sense to me some simulation this is
oh yeah you've got a $300,000 scorpion
came but you can't cut down a birch tree
no matter how often the farmers like all
those tree types unsupported doesn't
work go to where that the backup is
let's clear that tree out I'm feeling
guilty about that this car looks kind of
like it's backwards oh man look at oh
look at that death I'm so excited about
this I really understand what's gonna
happen when we find a tree that type
that is it's gonna cut it down man
come on are you serious
you've got to kidding me this is
[ __ ] it's not you should look at
this thing you should be able to cut
down anything with this it's a giant
transformer all right you know what oh
wait this machine cuts logs into lengths
it can't cut a tree that has large
amount of brackets because it won't fly
through the thing what it's for treason
you've already cleaned out
cut how do I cut it
change cut like how do I cut it
this is so frustrating we mortgaged your
house we spent every dime we had oh I'm
going to yeah oh yeah yeah get it get it
now what do we do
hashtag gotwood oh yeah oh this is so
sexy oh dude this is what I do at home
by myself you know what I'm saying this
is amazing this thing looks like you're
jerking off a tree I've never seen
always are working dude it totally
jerked off that tree
that was incredible wait check this out
dude this is worth every cent if you're
a farmer out there the end of the
Scorpion King get a Scorpion King stat
because this thing is amazing how do I
get this thing to go up there we go
y'all and I'm throwing logs around this
is the greatest day of my life how does
it go back down okay dude check this out
this is amazing this is like so this is
honestly I'm not even bullshitting it's
like the coolest thing watch this watch
oh this tree type is supported yeah yeah
get ready yep yeah cut it up so so now
what do you do you keep doing it no I
mean how do you how do you I don't know
I we sold everything else between these
logs anywhere but you know what it's so
fun wait check this out check this out
wait for it this is a really hard thing
to maneuver
oh yeah look at this
ah yes just death beeps this is the
greatest game ever made here we go here
we go son of a [ __ ]
turn turn the score Peking is crap here
we go
move down the road seems kind of
dangerous yes you're right now I laid up
I need a payload or the fork bucket for
transferring the logs the prob here's
the problem we sold everything to get
the Scorpion King now some people would
say that that's a bad strategy and they
would be right look at this little thing
cut it up this is so cool
dude you want to try this yes this is so
fun awesome all right trees who's next
who's next what trees been talking [ __ ]
there we go
can't get over the can't get over the
table that was that a better name is the
Woody Allen it's because it's got wood
in the name your abuela that's like the
woody harrelson that's right just make
one cut then drag it and sell it Specter
22 says Specter 22 thank you for your
help make one cut let me just drag the
whole thing so you want it you know hold
l1 put the thing down low put the arm
down low with the right stick yeah there
you go and then oh god oh no and then
yeah and then get in there l1 and then
yep then cut it I don't give you an
option to cut but it'll be X when you
get the thing the jetpack closer to the
thing yep do it Thanks
they just keep hitting next man I'm
dragging they're gonna drag it around oh
yeah this is awesome dude drag that tree
put it in the middle of the road
oh don't fall in the water
dishonest advertisement dude this thing
is called the Scorpion King and I have
to say pop what is it pop passe Ponce
Ponce is my favorite Thank You farming
equipment cuz they name their stuff cool
Ponson Ponson doing it right they got
some cool yellow black going on and find
out where i sell a tree right
Oh Forest Whitaker James Woods is good
to go to they map
there's that there's a forest thing
where's that
lumberyard is wrong way
if you operate this machine wrong in
real life that speaking of flying into
the window and kill the driver oh my god
that's crazy
you know what I bet I what if it does
that on the hard level you know I wonder
if it's cuz we're uneasy that it's like
it's kind of taking it easy on so I
can't really drive forward right with
this thing I think a lot of farmers
I feel like drive backward we should
tread right forward
but here's an idea here's an idea watch
this move put the thing behind us and
drag it this way
oh that's not a bad idea I guess
are they just gonna take a big full tree
like this let's see but a pump up of
metals here we go look at that speedy
how many rings are in there like four
it's trees out where so that's the
that's the largest four year old tree
right there yeah lift up the arm thank
you different camera how high does the
arm go by the way okay lift it all the
way up
right here we go we're gonna sell this
tree
would Elijah would that's a good name
hashed the hashtag pipe out to 15
because you see how they do you see the
blade at the bottom of it no it's really
cool quickly we're at what it uses to
chop a tree oh yeah
that machine is a cool machine yeah look
at that blade he's like yeah you see how
it oh yeah awesome do you think this
machine actually works that quickly in
real life no although somebody did say
hold the straight gunpoint somebody did
say it the stakes are high when using
this machine really I can kill you I
think leave it right
Briella Sarah
it's a long you know note to self cut
down trees closer to the young
lumberyard I guess that's why they have
lumber yards dude this is pretty dope
man I feel like this would be a pretty
pimp ride you pull up to the club in
this thing and a scorpion king what up
ladies I think you basically would go
home and no but Ellison there's no place
for another person to sit which may is
maybe a problem so is this the
lumberyard I can't see it's gonna be a
good Christmas I got a big old tree
there you go
tree surprise don't cut trees hey
necromancer don't tell me how to live up
here this guy where's all the wood gonna
come from I just dude this is a town
full of ghosts wait what is this is like
purgatory existential yeah this is
there's no end game yeah there's no
reward it's just endless focuses made a
game that's actually what happens to us
when we die you become a farmer in ghost
farm dude what if you you your soul goes
into this game these are actually real
people who have dear Lord you know what
I'm saying like these are real all right
I feel like I might be stuck right now
I'm just backing it up
well I don't think you're gonna be able
to sell this tree now I think so I think
I'm just gonna dump it right in the
water watch this just back for it I'm
almost done I've almost got it
there we go I'm free I'm almost free see
me check my POV here MPO tree here we go
three bucks on a tree and dragged it
into hey I just got everyone on the
stream is yelling at me right now I'm
almost out though here we go oh it's out
just this my tree keeps getting caught
on other trees all right here we go I'm
delivering it I'm gonna sell it there we
go we're gonna put it right in the river
here we go oh there we go I said I sell
the tree your farm is done what happened
to the tree it's gone we didn't even
sell the tree it's gone lame all right
well that'll do it for this episode of
but a melee thank you so much for
joining us
tree prey we played farm is 215 today
thank you so much Beth Moravsky a chair
in Chris well I wanted to sit Steven
Smith our last Monday melee you'll never
see me again don't worry go to Instagram
at sleep Smith Instagram and Twitter at
snakes and rats to follow this guy and
we'll be seeing him on another feeds and
that stuff thank you guys for joining us
you see you guys next Monday see you
later